repasser ou je n'aime pas la guerre
karine ferri irisnet nerfs et tenait à
aa
parce qu'ils sont venus jump attendez je
vais expliquer il semblerait semblerait
que iris müstair pousserait vers la
sortie
si on n'aime pas madame ferry karine
ferri à votre avis d'abord il faut dire
que tf1 n'aime pas quand les femmes sont
enceintes et doivent partir en congés de
maternité moi tu peux dire ça c'est déjà
passé avec l'adie flamand vous confirmez
benjamin c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'après un mois travaillés carole
rousseau savait qu'à la moindre travail
mais est ce que c'est la raison ou pas
bah en tout cas à chaque fois ça s'est
reproduit ci ouais mais c'est pas la
seule chaîne nous arrête ça si ces
sommes étaient malheureux et c'est
triste parce que c'est pas une maladie
d'être enceinte mais ce que vous pensez
vraiment il ya une guerre entre les deux
je suis passé via une guerre entre les
deux et moi je suis tout à fait du côté
de karine ferri
j'aime son combat j'aime sa rébellion
j'aime le fait qu'elle propose plein
d'émissions plein d'idées elle ne
renonce pas elle sent quiris mittenaere
est en train de lui pendant que sarah le
temps et je trouve j'ai des infos et la
manière la manière dont elles résistent
me plaît je l'admiré énormément voilà
allez-vous sa révolte et a vu des
papiers dans les geôles ans elle dit je
suis révolté alstare hangar
problème n'est pas la peine de risquer
tonnerre pour l'animation de l'animation
colis data annonce j'ai entendu on m'a
dit que stonehenge à voir ailleurs elle
était très bien dans l'empathie avec
nicoletta mais lorsqu'il s'agissait de
lancer au compteur il y avait encore
quelques petites difficultés marc
l'aller simple
les à la face au yen à mon avis je pense
que yoann gourcuff risque de signer à
dubaï donc il ya beaucoup maintenant
deux ans ça va nous amener au sujet
d'après de serveurs peut-être que là
elles sont peut-être sa place par tiers
donc si lui par à dubaï ville de foot à
dow
oui il a plusieurs et c'est une super
aventure
[Applaudissements]